in 45 seconds all your life can change
and actually what is important to do
that because it's
sometimes we are running so much in our
life we want to do everything but one
second actually can change everything
and can collapse and can build
welcome to 20 minute leaders just sit
back relax and learn from the leaders of
today it's a journey each one is
different unique inspiring let's get
started
[Music]
this episode is powered by j ventures a
community driven vc fund in silicon
valley in partnership with lumitec
sponsored by homeward ventures hippo
insurance opposed labs synergy global
hillel at stanford leap birthright excel
serona partners and in media partnership
with ctec
hello hello and welcome to 20 minute
leaders we have an extraordinary story
today with us please meet lisa manoak
senior partner at catalyst fund since
2019. lisa holds over 15 years of
investment and management experience in
private equity and global leading
corporations in particular in the
context of m a transactions post-merger
integration and raising capital lisa has
previously led the operational due
diligence for the acquisition of kettle
group by bc partners and managed
post-acquisition integration
prior to quettel lisa held management
positions in one of the world's leading
crop protection companies adama and its
magnus thayer bmw
lisi has a multicultural background
speaking fluent german turkish english
and hebrew she earned an mba from tel
aviv university msc from vienna
university of technology and harvard
executive
welcome to 20 minute leaders thank you
so much for joining me today how are you
thank you very much hi michael thank you
very much having me how are you
i am doing great i'm really excited for
these 20 minutes talking about
you know your work and most importantly
your journey um
very non-traditional journey very
different from that of i guess pretty
much every uh guest i've had on the show
and so i i want to start there
and i want to understand a little bit
better you know who you are today
obviously you're you're an integral part
of the the israel ecosystem and the
investment ecosystem with catalyst
and
sitting on the board and supporting some
of the most phenomenal companies in the
israel ecosystem but but we'll get to
that well i want to start a little bit
about where you're from
and so share with me a little bit about
you know your upbringing and your
the the way you eventually got into tech
okay let's do it
um
i think for me at least it all comes
back from back to where we begin from
and indeed it is true i had a atypical
childhood i am born in a small island in
istanbul in turkey
i grew up with four generations in a
jewish family and my families were
educational freaks or i went from a
childhood to german schools
practically at the age of the 17 decided
to go there to austria and to study
mechanical engineering
and after one year studying the
mechanical engineering with 500 people
over 500 people
so i remembered that the day that i was
calling my family take me back i can't
do it anymore that's it
i tried but i'm failing
and i will never forget my family told
me that listen lisa but you got the
internship in bmw
don't reject but even if you are
rejecting go there and
tell that face to pace that you cannot
work there
so practically i packed my bag i went to
grass and went into the factory that was
the biggest factory that i started in my
life at that time wow so i entered into
the
door and it was a wrong door it was the
general management rooms which i was not
a bear at the age of the 17 and a half
so
and
i i just
went in and i said that listen i am very
grateful and thankful but i cannot do
that the internship thank you very much
i'm going back to my country and he told
me first i believe that
you are in the wrong room and second i
never took that any intern in my life
but you you will stay and you will be my
intern
and
you will enjoy it
and it was the the game changing in my
life i stayed nine years there
yes and
i called my back my family and i said
that stop i'm not
coming that relocating to turkey i am
yes staying in austria in vienna graz
munich i was there in three cities
and
yeah and i live by myself nine years
working in a mechanical engineer
and
where no one was even talking that about
the recycling here it was 15 years ago
it was my master thesis it was about
biodegradable materials in the
automotive industry it's funny today
that we are talking that everything
needs to be that recycled and we are
investing that in the everything which
is related to the recycling and
sustainability
but yes it was a great journey and 11
years ago i moved to israel and that's
another journey in wildlife
what what was it in in that moment that
you know you go there to tell them that
you're not taking the internship
you know if you look back really it's
sort of this interaction that you've had
with with your future boss what what was
it that really made him you know
both want to play and convince you to
stay actually i asked then
this question because up to that moment
i didn't know that the meaning of the
board meetings and the age of the 17 and
a half where you are learning that the
first degree the first year of your
school you don't yet to know that the
big words that and what are they doing
and everything
and literally it was taking me that
everywhere to each meetings to all the
suppliers to the negotiations and to
everything
and when i asked that later on couple
years later
what was the interest that he took me
that there's the intern
he said he really appreciated that i
moved all the way three hours i took it
and i didn't just then email to standard
thank you very much you have selected
out of all students only me
but i cannot come no you came and you
told me that face to face and this is
the best behavioral attitude that you
can do that to any person in your life
and we appreciate
and that that was the reason actually he
took me wow
and he taught me that the mechanical
engineering including all everyone in
the group
and
why did you
spend those three hours going there and
telling them in person when he could
have you know called them
you know
that's also great um a question in the
in turn came
i i lived in turkey in uh born in turkey
in istanbul
and
i'm in my whole family is very young so
i grew up with four generations
and literally i saw that mother of my
grandmother so we were all together in
the family
and one beautiful thing that i learned
from many things i learned but many
values that you are learning is that
respect and respect to each other to
other generations and also to younger
generations have to speak
and
have to give that
respect to the elder one or to the
younger one even if you do not agree
that with their opinion
to be to show that the empathy to look
that from their point of view
so it's all the time it was like
injected in my blood
uh because
uh
grew up with all of them together
and uh it was very important and still
today i'm grateful
that they taught me that these important
values like respect and making be able
to do that empathy to the each other
and that was the reason
i went all the way
today is that three hours is nothing but
at that time that
uh you know it was that more simple for
for a younger person to take the flight
come back to the family where you were
living alone and there was no whatsapp
no skype and no nothing
no zoom
so
yes
now if we go just to before that just a
bit because i want to make sure i
understand
you know part of your upbringing and
sort of this this special circumstance
was also um
diverting from the traditional path
perhaps that that one would assume you
you went to a
you went to a different type of school
right where you you had a nun and
primarily muslim
what was sort of the
the reasoning behind because you did
grow up in a jewish household right yes
i'm i'm jewish i grew up in a jewish
household in a zionist household
actually and
i was
mad i was teaching i was very very
active in the jewish organizations from
the very young age
and you are right turkey is that today
the majority over 90 percent is the
muslim culture
and yet indeed
everything my family was educational
freak so they didn't decide to send me
their two cents to a jewish school maybe
it was the typical situation at that day
so they wanted that i'm taking one of
the
best education and at that time that the
german schools were giving that very
good education that bilingual with
german and with french and
english
so after the doing that many psychometry
there so i entered the inside but the
short story incurs
the diversity and the different
religions is that
part of me that from a very very young
childhood so i i knew that what is
christmas and how to celebrate eastern
or
to make that uh to celebrate the jewish
holidays
and to be respectful to all muslim
holidays and to have that muslim friends
and
the diversity that when you are injected
again to your
childhood that
you are not judging anyone actually
because you are taking and you are
respecting that everyone as it is
and
no one is better than you
um
i mean i think it's obviously one it's
one thing for
you know children around the world to
learn that you're to respect diversity
and to respect the others and to
appreciate that the differences but but
it's another thing to to live it
and to literally
to live it and to take it normal you
know it's not like that's special so you
are born with it and it's the normal
part of your life so nobody is judging
you for
being that different from the others on
the contrary so this to be a different
in and
it gives you that different skills
that's um from every perspective and
even when i decided in my family that to
study mechanical engineering today many
people ask me that someone judged you so
it was very normal nobody asked me that
are you sure you are a woman you want to
study in mechanical engineering it's not
a typical so
yes i am
in that perspective i'm really really
grateful
that um
that i was giving that the possibility
from the childhood that
in a diverse culture religions different
countries and turkey israel austria i
went for one year to boston so
to to live with the different people all
around the world
incredible
if you're transitioning now to
sort of
today with with israel and uh
and being a part of the israeli
ecosystem here
sort of how do you see your role you
know in the in the ecosystem today
let me start with
where what i'm doing there today i'm
partnered with catalyst funds and for me
it was uh
actually from first of all it was not my
plan to join that a vc or private equity
from the get-go so okay so i was an
engineer and jumped it into the
financial life and decades ago when i
moved to israel i was doing a lot of
mnas and when i jumped from the mnas
to the post-merging integration and to
private equity who bought that qatar
group so then i was suddenly on the buy
side from the side i jumped to the buy
side
and
i really loved it to be able that on
that point to invest
and that's
uh that was that my decision point when
i was doing the post-merging integration
okay so i need to join the vc
and luckily so i joined the private
equity slash venture capital actually
that is existing over 23 years so right
with three partners existing over 23
years all of them together
and i joined as a fourth partner almost
four years ago
and
we are supporting i am supporting the
entrepreneurs my only goal is that
support them and bring them more success
it's all about the people at the end so
you want to add added value where from
every perspective from the technical
perspective from the financial
perspective to bring them to financial
institutions preparing them uh to the
exit uh making that the other
possibilities on the technical
perspective to open the rnd centers all
over the world so that that's my passion
on the other side which i love today is
that
uh being in contact day by day with the
investors
because the to gain their trust and to
understand them and to add added value
uh to be able that to the co-invest with
them in the companies in the sectors
where they love
it is
for me unmeasurable so
this is the wow i enjoyed it every day
doing that
and and if you look back at your
mechanical engineering self or
you know the places that the things
you've done throughout your life it's
it's part of a different work
do you have that same satisfaction is it
the same satisfaction is it a different
type of satisfaction between what you're
doing now and what you did before
is completely different
and also mnas are that different what i
was doing before but the investment
in the vc ecosystem is
combining everything so it gives me
still that opportunity
to bring my technical knowledge to the
companies
where i can bring and there is a
language in the automotive industry or
there's a language in the energy it's
not only the language that you speak
german it's not like that it's that
half the tier ones are talking oh yeah
these are talking that and
if i can
give that added value for me it's great
i was working four and a half years in
one of the biggest agro company it's
called adamant
modern so i
today one of my patients is that to add
added value to the agrotech companies
and food tech companies because if i
haven't learned that if i wouldn't work
there and i wouldn't work that in 52
subsidiaries of the adama today i
wouldn't be not in the position that to
give such a big added value to the
companies that we are investing in
and from the financial perspective is
that all the m as the over
ten years um doing the n s in the other
mine qatar group and the post-merger
integration
so that was the linkage actually between
the company and with the financial
institutions
and
our at the end our goal is that to bring
that the companies to scale up and to
bring them to the exit and this is where
we can help them uh through the m as
through the ipo and
yes it's it's
definitely a great added value
the background what i've done and i
appreciate i'm still learning every day
i think there is never a age that you
can stop learning yeah but yes and so
if
if we're sort of going 30 000 feet in
the air and
you know there's so many different
things that you've done throughout your
career so many different experiences
um
sort of
how do you see
you know what what you're who you are or
what do you want to do
right i mean it's a it's a weird
question but but what i'm getting at is
you know you've seen so many different
parts of the world so many different
industries so many different types of
people and types of lifestyles
and if you're thinking today about what
makes you happy
you know what makes you fulfilled
intellectually
emotionally
you know family ways sort of
how do you how do you distill it down
what did you learn about yourself
throughout these years of doing all
these different experiences
yeah
i will answer in two answers then so
them
when i was young and it was a big
earthquake when i was in istanbul 1999 i
will never forget because it was like
for the longest 45 seconds in your life
and when you go out from the the
building you see that a lot of damage
buildings and many people died
unfortunately and you see that you you
leave that
and on that moment you think that
uh it's like in 45 seconds all your life
can change and actually what is
important to do that because it's
sometimes we are running so much in our
life we want to do everything but one
second actually can change everything
and can collapse and can be
on that day and
i promise myself
that
i i want to be in a position in my life
that as much i'm taking i want to give
it also
and
for me it's the very very important uh
it's the from the investment perspective
where i'm sitting there today
yes i'm grateful that the investors are
trusting and giving that millions of
dollars
that we can invest in there and to make
that the right decisions in the company
and on the other side we are supporting
we are helping the technical echo the
ecosystem we are giving we are creating
jobs we are
making that the israeli companies even
bigger
and we are on that
market situations
if our high-tech companies can hire that
additional hundred people
i i am thankful for that because 100
people it means that for hundreds of
people they have families and they have
their children and to be on the position
that to be able to give is that the most
important thing
and i hope i will continue that whatever
i do in my life
that as much as i'm taking it i want to
be able that to give
and phenomenal actually israel has
changed that a lot in me because on that
earthquake israel
israeli rescue system and rescue team
came and they saved one
boy three years old boy after six days
he was standing there in the earthquake
without food without water without
anything
and
for me it was like um
[Music]
you know enormous when you leave that
and when you see that
and
you just want to be in a position that
you should you want to be on the rescue
team you want to be able that to help
that to the people you want to make the
companies bigger and
um and everything
alicia it's a it's fascinating and it's
inspiring i really appreciate your time
and your energy it's a such a phenomenal
story and
and thank you for everything that you're
doing
and thank you for this inspiration i
loved it thank you michael thank you
very much thank you for having me and i
appreciate it
of course